à travers leur histoire la question de
l'avenir des Ukrainiens en France à
Blois une quarantaine d'entre eux
doivent quitter le foyer dans lequel ils
sont hébergés gracieusement depuis
plusieurs mois tout en proposant des
relancements la préfecture les presse de
trouver un emploi sous peine de devoir
bien tout rentrer dans leur pays en
guerre les Turquie avec Lucas Chopin
tout sur les portes le même message
fermeture définitive ici une quarantaine
d'Ukrainiens sont sur le départ leurs
affaires s'accumulent dans le hall nous
avons rencontré trois d'entre eux le
sentiment dominant c'est l'inquiétude un
couple nous a raconté ne pas savoir où
ils seront logés dans à peine quelques
jours nous avons aussi fait la
connaissance d'Anna tatoué en Ukraine
elle avait retrouvé un travail également
en tant que tatoueuse à proximité du
foyer seulement Anna nous explique avoir
dû abandonné cette piste au profit des
emplois proposés par la préfecture dès
lundi tous devront quitter les lieux en
raison de travaux de réhabilitation à
l'accueil une employée du bailleur
social terre de loi rabbita propriétaire
des murs nous indique ne pas avoir le
droit de s'exprimer sur le sujet le
foyer meunier était mise à disposition
de la préfecture du Loir-et-Cher pour
accueillir ces réfugiés en attendant des
solutions de relogement il devrait être
accueillis à l'auberge de jeunesse de
Vendôme la la semaine prochaine